okay so let's talk about another type of
cue called pool cues this cue solves
another kind of problem let's say that
you implemented a site that require
humans to review comments so the users
of the site generate comments and these
comments need to be reviewed before they
are published similarly to push cues you
could create a cue and then insert
comments to be reviewed into this cue as
tasks and external people well in our
case robots could review the comments
perhaps working from home in their spare
time so you have your cue where you add
comments as review tasks then the
different people would pull a review
task from the queue and work on it so
let's look at the difference with push
queues well in this case App Engine is
not executing the tasks they are instead
executed by the external workers you can
say that the task is pulled from the
queue by the external worker that's why
they are called pull queues the tasks
that are pulled from the queue are
leased by the external workers the
worker must complete the task within the
least time in which case it can be
deleted but if the task is not completed
within the least time it is
automatically returned to the queue if
you compare pull queues to push queues
the differences are the pull queues do
not have a URL since your code is not
completing the task each task is leased
by a worker for a certain amount of time
a worker must delete the task when it's
completed otherwise it is returned when
the lease expires external workers pull
the queue using a rest interface and
there is no default queue for pull
queues so you need to explicitly create
them that's it for pokies let's have a
quiz